I'm talking to mr. George scott who was
a hold up during the time of the building
of the bridge. Do you remember how you
first got the job to mr.
Scott. Yes i play there working cockatoo
and then i left there played in the bridge
for
a job and they tell me to conduct tomorrow
morning and start. What was who who did
you interviewed you were on the bridge.
They did very was the pool and then and
they knew him so he said just come and start
so i went back to cover ten kidman oh
the sin and started and. Do you know i
know you need overbuying before and island
to do. Yes and you did very were boys
together went to school in the same club and
came out here together. Did you work in the
shipyards in ireland. Yes work in hand
will stand workmen and
clerks. And you and dave
a band came out together to do we
commit here together yes. And in 1924
i think it was yes twenty four. And what
was your job on the bridge holding on. I
was holding on the chap called ned kelly
the chap that there low but not at that
particular time but i worked with him for
three years and. Then i got another mate
and he got another mate that
he was working there he was
a look at their lower bridge if it worked
with him for the three years. When you
worked as
a holder or how old or up. Did you work
on the arts or in the workshops need from
the beginning at this stage say to the
middle in the ij on the south side. Could
you describe the job of holding up. Can
you how it goes on. Yes. Where do you get
a call as
a rattler dulé. Nigga adjusted to
the rivet page stated if you want
opinion and. Even the riveter can you put
it in the hole and put this rattler gully
on an atlas and the other side knocked the
river down. Who was the the rivets were
all sent down to you and
a compressed air line web site at the
finish. But at the beginning it capped at
first no ordinary cook trying to divert
for five in the parrot once and then kid.
Vol.
Number until they got more hot and and
minutes time to put one in the hole to give
it a hold on to give the hole on
a fitted and evident up to down. What
if you were close enough. He'd hand it
straight over seven mostly worked on the
approach is particularly are you were
quite right along the approaches that you
read along to the very beginning of the
middle and then on the
roadway to. Four and
a half years. To was the one was the work
very hard very very hard work because the
you had
a drift every hole pretty just threw every
hole with no teacher thing is reaming or
anything like that they all had
a very distinct until you get the rivet in.
And what was the conditions like inside
the cords very hard and they're always
on the arch was always on a slope in
a hurry. It was always seem to be in
two years you can think. Do you know
remember any particular dangerous incidents
where you were nearly in trouble
yourself. Well yes i can sure you might
hear. I was working down and put don't know
and the bottom cord an area that
fell from another on top and make it
a don't and i see it took me to set policies
teeth and black and you can see the
mike there yet. And incidentally no
compensation for broken teeth rennie thing in
those days. So you got no compensation for
that comes only just come before we know
but not from
a teeth never broken beyond repair. Who
are you. When you burn to death with
a cricket was
a call to open the top and then just read
up the face and two black eyes. How long
we are off. I can tell you no suppose about
it. It was long time ago and the idea
because the first two member any incidents
that happen to other people dangerous
incidents. Well i serve make needed getting
killed. He was the first one to get
hill scratch up call mcneill i can't
think of his first team for to
a knocking off and had to get work on the
approach the very beginning and even then
the latter and he still fairly
was the first have to get
a killer scratched called
mcneill yes he had
a two names actually he was known as it
would make me ill and the tamil swan bells
. So they covered i don't
buy make nearly as
a moment. Very well and i was at that show.
Practically per say them as haven't i
can remember any other incidents like where
i was clearly huge just like that now
nearest cape so you had and of it only
heard and then in germany near misses near
nearest grapes and very likely all the way
through years going to be carefree and i
was careful if we all told all told to
be very very careful to no how much
a week. You got yesterday for turn
eighteen plus whatever hate deva working
on forever elevation that had
a vehicle. For the end up the more you got
her that's in the middle. I think you
are getting more money then you're
weeks wages were. Do you remember
whether that was much more than you
got in ireland quite a lot more quite
a lot more it was much work and ireland
there was data and i left there was is
a passion which is starting them didn't
had to stay live till the foot 1928
twenty nine. And when you finished up on
the bridge were you out of work or did you
get a job. Everybody else he was out of
work there for months and then you got
a job in new guinea and i stayed there
for twenty one years. Except for
the evacuation evacuated during
the war. That building gold
dredges in a first class building
all day just with a rule
a golden age in company. I went back
there after the war and say there's
a name 10:53 and that and the waif
and everyone terrible at it had
a nuff so give it away. For him
back again to the to the bridge
. On the approach spans when you were
working along were. Was there anything
anything different about working
on them. Oh yes it was just
a whole street level go
on the murder of you
a world level but on the arches
the said in the audience
a chord you were always on the slope. And
it was pretty sore in your feet. It had
at the end of the day. Do you remember about
the working conditions in those days.
Yes
a there is no locker rooms are just
the humpy next door to where they
pick up boys for the wifely average but
there's no locker room just to hang your
coat up there when the whistle blowers pay
the clock you didn't knock off the five
no washbasin just picture caught on to
cure overalls of come home that was it was
nothing no time will wash up for anything
like that now. Do you remember any union
activity what do you know you're in those
days i was in there in virginia in those
days and at the local tunick i think with
the secretary snow we didn't have much
travel but weather was her greatest trouble.
The company said oh you can work if
you want to. But the department of main
roads which you really can't work in the
rain and because the contracts the rivets
and wrecks the rivers who were there. Yes
between the both ims and one when did we
get work wanted we couldn't have its way
into the papers twenty minutes never did
they. It was pretty hard. Do you remember
also whether there was a me
lunch. Arranges where you had
a lunch room or anything like that.
No lunch just in this humpy or e have
a red strand they are a kind of
thing in the wintertime itself in
a garden old you know lunchrooms new to
continue nothing like that now with the
court slippery in the morning. Yes there
were always two wet or something like that
. And when the time was. When the wind
blows it is very very cold and wet and
miserable to get warmed
up a bit when she had
a few bits in there in the cord well-studied
warm up of it. Remember getting burnt
at all. Now and i used to wear long gloves
to hear countless no use to keep those
on mostly all day and i think it went out
about scaling their boots and yes they
had their it ever had good boots to wear
years out of the village. How did you keep
the scale out of the tops of the boots.
You're over also came over the top of me
and it and didn't much much chance and
that. Several in the workshops used to get
claims for compensation because the scale
in their boots. They did and therefore
have treated and get that they say very
much. Only worked in the shop two months
and then they wanted said. Had left cover
too and then went straight vigin that
tova and paid just before christmas that
year twenty six haven't stayed and stayed
thirty one. Were you up on the arch when
it was joined. Yes i was up nights but we
weren't allowed near little mr innes
knees. People were all there. There for
a little reason there and what have you.
And we were just fact cheered when it
happened. Did you were you there. The
following morning when it went up to canberra
to bob a good mechanic. That was like a
lot more change we got to the ship in
a circular quay at went west. So
you didn't get yours engraved
bone. You didn't get yours engraved no
i didn't. Expanded that discipline.
Well i'm told by some of the
people that they're worth
a thousand dollars. Now i don't know there's
any truth in this. I don't think it
looked in that they get it. Is there
any other events you can remember
while they were working up there.
Do you remember the rigging of the staging
was it good work. Yes it was very good
work said daley was there was the foreman
there and. Tappy evans is one of his
squad and i knew him very well and he
went in new guinea also have that image.
Everything was rated you could hardly
for trade and lacy. But everything was
permanent except for you. Who didn't have
any safety ropes everywhere or safety
nets to the unknown. Oh
nothing like that only
a rope around the stage of his early that
just stand there and hold it said daly
said the power of feeling kept you
see it kinda thing just turned
a moment. Do you remember who the
dog when the riggers were. Ben
i forget is of the name and the leading
hand nigga jack benson. Ben used to
have the phones in the telephone
to talk to clean and jack king
wanted of much lower the fitter all fit
the causes of this coming into position.
Do you remember any of our other crime
drivers do now. They were on the so say they
never worked on this side but you had
three or four kind drivers in the creeper
crammed into and i was only one
and so said me didn't work on
a shift when it was day shift and the king
was the only one that i know and i don't
mean that i was trying to understand that
there were several chrome drivers in the
one you know all the
cranes on around there was
a walking crane along the front had
a driver the main creeper crone had the
driver and then they had drivers for around
the back for the for lifting your tools up
and that sort of thing you know kind of
over there was really when was the main
ones and it's all home. How did you go up
in the cradle. We went up in that box
a fair and pointed left the front
and that's for the arch front turn
in the sturgis way and with it for fifty
feet and. Was just an ordinary box of
boards and when it came to the vigil very
very would grasp it. And hang on and get
a just quick is a kidney seam
coming down a delay. She was
a walk the walk of which is
a long way to go which crane driver
drove. Joking. He drove as well
from the he drove that from the creeper
cree and because there was anyway it could
come up. Yes. It was red. He drew the even
if there was only create and there are
today. Remember yes. This is just that
several people have told me that there were
more than one crane driver on that until i
can see at least three drivers boxes on
the on the creeper cram one for the main
crane for lifting the main left all around
the place and they had
a jigger hoist which went on the on the
end of that and then there was also
a walking crane that went along
separately underneath and that's got
a chrome travis box which is separate from
the other one i just wondering who are
drove the other one. I can't remember that
and i really can't remember that. Now i
think anymore do you remember anything else
about about going up and down. Did you
always get get the credit allotted sometimes
have to walk when they started when
they got the road way they started then
they put an elevator. Again the thing in
that was easy. Just as in the grand
with it. Elevated no good and took
a turn to put on the active was nothing
like that. You know they all went up in
this box and waited and frontin in the
water the middle of the harbour if it was
and he food and condone get known but
i tell you what i do and no need to
judge. Lucas he was the judge at that time
of their of attrition and he was the one
to decide how much money they should have
gotten but we didn't get their hate money
. This particular day came down for
a tad and sell so many get on that pontoon
box in the middle of the harbor. It
started to blow and swear that but it
didn't go up that up this way and was too
much you come down. We got our money.
That's true. Remember that. There's
some of these said that the
mauve occasion they had
a number of politicians came out of. To
try it out and they had crawled across
various bits and pieces. Credibly that i
remember something like that pretended and
see it myself but i remember that george
lucas very well. He never even got up the
talk. Do you remember the
difference between working in
freedom and longs in sydney and working for
harlem wharf in belfast. Yes and whole
world our ownership particularly this is
the indian works which i didn't work with
there for the ownership.
When you start working on
a ship. He just take your coat off
and hang it up on a nail and then
a boat or river the nearest to you and
leave it there and and lunchtime comes you
have learned just a round of it.
There is no comfort. I have
a conduct no way should do nothing. Just
take your coat put it on the get off nine
your way home. Anything else. And
jim member they had
a washing facilities and fast washing
facilities and certainly for that matter. He
didn't have any working facilities and
there was person who was there and there's
not very many in sydney and certainly he
had to wonder why in dorm long's you had
a desert in your own tent there's no five
minutes for anything allowed away she
just and people that live very handy.
They just didn't buy they just particular
tournament home.